MICHALE FEE: OK.
All right, let's go
ahead and get started.
OK, so we're going
to continue talking
about the topic of
neural networks.
Last time, we introduced
a new framework
for thinking about neural
network interactions,
using a rate model to describe
the interactions of neurons
and develop a mathematical
framework for how
to combine
collections of neurons
to study their behavior.
So, last time, we introduced
the notion of a perceptron
as a way of building
a neural network that
can classify its inputs.
And we started talking about the
notion of a perceptron learning
rule, and we're going
to flesh that idea out
in more detail today.
We're going to then talk about
the idea of using networks
to perform logic with neurons.
We're going to talk about the
idea of linear separability
and invariance.
Then we're going to
introduce more complex
feed-forward networks,
where instead
of having a single
output neuron,
we have multiple output neurons.
Then we're going to turn to
a more fully developed view
of the math that we use to
describe neural networks,
and matrix operations
become extremely important
in neural network theory.
And then, finally,
we're going to turn
to some of the kinds
of transformations that
are performed by
matrix multiplication
and by the kinds of-- by
feed-forward neural networks.
OK, so we've been considering
a kind of neural network called
a rate model that uses firing
rates rather than spike trains.
So we introduced
the idea that we
have an output neuron
with firing rate
v that receives input
from an input neuron that
has firing rate u.
The input neuron synapses
onto the output neuron
with a synapse of weight w.
And we described
how we can think
of the input neuron producing a
synaptic input into the output
neuron that has a
magnitude of the firing
rate times the strength of
the synaptic connection.
So the input to the output
neuron here is w times u.
And then we talked about how we
can convert that input current,
let's say, into
our output neuron
into a firing rate of the output
neuron through some function
f, which is what's called the
F-I curve of the neuron that
relates the input to the
firing rate of the neuron.
And we talked about
several different kinds
of F-I firing rate versus input
functions that can be useful.
We then extended our network
from a single input neuron
synapsing onto a
single output neuron
by having multiple
input neurons.
Again, the output neuron
has a firing rate,
and our input neurons have a
vector of firing rates now--
u1, u2, u3, u4, and so on--
that we can combine
together into a vector, u.
Each one of those input neurons
has a synaptic strength w
onto our output neuron.
So we have a vector
of synaptic strengths.
And now we can write down the
input current to our output
neuron as a sum of the
contributions from each
of those input neurons-- so w1,
u1 plus w2, u2, plus w3, u3,
and so on.
So we can now write
the input current
to our output neuron as
a sum of contributions
that we can then write
as a dot product--
w dot u.
OK, any questions about that?
And so, in general, we have
the firing rate of our output
neuron is just
this F-I function,
this input-output function
of our output neuron acting
on the total input,
which is w dot u.
And then we talked
about different kinds
of functions that are
useful computationally
for this function f.
So in the context of the
integrate and fire neuron,
we talked about F-I curves that
are zero below some threshold
and then are linear above
that threshold current.
We talked last time about
a binary threshold known
that has zero firing
rate below some threshold
and then steps up abruptly to
a constant output firing rate
one.
And then we also introduced,
last time, the notion
of a linear neuron,
whose firing rate is
just proportional
to the input current
and has positive and
negative firing rates.
And we talked about the
idea that although it's
biophysically implausible
to have neurons
that have negative
firing rates, that this
is a particularly useful
simplification of neurons.
Because we can just
use linear algebra
to describe the properties of
networks of linear neurons.
And we can do some
really interesting things
with that kind of
mathematical simplification.
We're going to get to
some of that today.
And that allows
you to really build
an intuition for what
neural networks can do.
OK, so let's come back to what
perceptron is and introduce
this perceptron learning role.
So we talked about the idea
that a perceptron carries out
a classification
of its inputs that
represent different features.
So we talked about classifying
animals into dogs and non-dogs
based on two
features of animals.
We talked about
the fact that you
can't make that classification
between dogs and non-dogs
just on the basis of
one of those features,
because these two categories
overlap in this feature
and in this feature.
And so in order to properly
separate those categories,
you need a decision
boundary that's
actually a combination
of those two features.
And we talked about
how you can implement
that using a simple
network, called
a perceptron, that has an output
neuron and two input neurons.
Each one of those input neurons
represents the magnitude
of those two different
features for each object
that you're trying to classify.
So u1 here and u2 are the
dimensions on which we're
performing this classification.
And so we talked about the fact
that that decision boundary
between those two
classifications
is determined by
this weight matrix w.
And then we used a
binary threshold neuron
for making the actual decision.
Binary threshold neurons are
great for making decisions,
because unlike a linear
neuron-- so a linear neuron just
responds more if
its input is larger,
and it responds less if
its input is smaller.
Binary threshold neurons
have a very clear threshold
below which the
neuron doesn't spike
and above which the
neuron does spike.
So, in this case, this network,
this output neuron here,
will fire, will have
a firing rate of one,
for any input that's on this
side of the decision boundary
and will have a
firing rate of zero
for any input that's on this
side of the decision boundary,
OK?
All right, so we talked about
how we can, in two dimensions,
just write down a decision
boundary that will separate,
let's say, green objects
from red objects.
So you can see that
if you sat down
and you looked at this drawing
of green dots and red dots,
that it would be very simple
to just look at that picture
and see that if you put
a decision boundary right
there, that you would be able
to separate the green dots
from the red dots.
How would you actually
calculate the weight vector
that that corresponds
to in a perceptron?
Well, it's very simple.
You can just look at where
that decision boundary crosses
the axes--
so you can see here, that
decision boundary crosses
the u1 axis at point A, crosses
the u2 axis at, I should say,
a value of B. And then we can
use those numbers to actually
calculate the w.
So, remember, u is
the input space.
w is a weight vector
that we're trying
to calculate in order
to place the decision
boundary at that point.
Is that clear what
we're trying to do here?
OK, so we can calculate
that weight vector.
We assume that just
data is some number.
Let's just call it one.
We have an equation for a
line-- w dot u equals theta.
That's the equation for
that decision boundary.
We have two knowns, the two
points on the decision boundary
that we can just
read off by eye.
And we have two unknowns-- the
synaptic weights, w1 and w2.
And so we have two equations--
ua dot w equals theta,
ub dot w equals theta.
And we can just
solve for w1 and w2,
and that's what you got, OK?
So the weight vector that gives
you that decision boundary
is 1 over a and 1 over b, OK?
Those are the two weights.
Any questions about that?
OK.
So in two dimensions, that's
very easy to do, right?
You can just look at
that cloud of points,
decide where to draw a line
that best separates the two
categories that you're
interested in separating.
But in higher dimensions,
that's really hard.
So in high dimensions,
for example,
we're trying to separate
images, for example.
So we can have a bunch
of images of dogs,
a bunch of images of cats.
Each pixel in that
image corresponds
to a different input to
our classification unit.
And now how do you decide
what all of those weights
should be from all of
those different pixels
onto our output neuron that
separates images of one class
from images of another class?
So there's just no way to do
that by eye in high dimensions.
So you need an
algorithm that helps
you choose that set of
weights that allows you
to separate different classes--
you know, a bunch of images
of one class from a bunch
of images of another class.
And so we're going to
introduce a method called
the perceptron learning rule
that is a category of learning
rules called supervised learning
rules that allow you to take
a bunch of objects that
you know-- so if you
have a bunch of
pictures of dogs,
you know that they're dogs.
If you have a bunch of pictures
of cats, you know they're cats.
So you label those images.
You feed those inputs, those
images, into your network,
and you tell the network
what the answer was.
And through an
iterative process,
it finds all of the weights that
optimally separate those two
different categories.
So that's called the
perceptron learning rule.
So let me just set up
how that actually works.
So you have a bunch of
observations of the input.
So in this case, I'm drawing
these in two dimensions,
but you should think about each
one of these dots as being,
let's say, an image of a
dog in very high dimensions,
where instead of just u1 and
u2, you have u1 through u1000,
where each one of those is
the value of a different pixel
in your image.
So you have a bunch of images.
Each one of those corresponds
to an image of a dog.
to an image of a cat.
And we have a whole bunch
of different observations
or images of those
different categories.
Any questions about that?
All right, so we have n
of those observations.
And for each one of
those observations,
we say that the
input is equal to one
of those observations for one
iteration of this learning
process, OK?
And so with each
observation, we're
told whether this
input corresponds
to one category or another,
so a dog or a non-dog.
And our output, we're asking--
we want to choose
this set of weights
such that the output
of our network
is equal to some known value.
So t sub i, where if it's a dog,
then the answer is one for yes.
If it's a non-dog, the answer
is no for that's not a dog.
And we have n of those answers.
We have n images and labels
that tell us what category
that image belongs to.
So for all of
these, t equals one.
For all of these, t equals zero.
And we want to find
a set of weights
such that when we take the dot
product of that weight factor
into each one of those
observations minus theta
that we get an answer
that is equal to t
for each observation.
Does that make sense?
So how do we do that?
All right, so each observation,
we have two things--
the input and the
desired output.
And that gives us
information that we
can use to construct
this weight vector.
So, again, that's called
supervised learning.
And we're going to use an
update rule, or a learning rule,
that allows us to
change the weight
vector on as a result
of each estimate,
depending on whether we got
the answer right or not.
So how do we do this?
What we're going to
do is we're going
to start with a random set
of weights, w1 and w2, OK?
And we're going to
put in an input.
So there's a space of inputs.
We're going to start
with some random weight,
and I started with some random
vector in this direction.
You can see that that gives you
a classification boundary here.
And you can see that that
classification boundary is not
very good for separating the
green dots from the red dots.
Why?
Because it will assign
a one to everything
on this side of that
decision boundary and a zero
to everything on that side.
But you can see
that that does not
correspond to the
assignment of green and red
to each of those dots, OK?
So how do we update that w in
order to get the right answer?
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to put in one of these
inputs on each iteration
and ask whether the network
got the answer right or not.
So we're going to put
in one of those inputs.
So let's pick that
input right there.
We're going to put
that into our network.
And we see that the answer
we get from the network
is one, because it's on the
positive side of the decision
boundary.
And so one was the right
answer in this case.
So what do we do?
We don't do anything.
We say the change in weight is
going to be zero if we already
get the right answer.
So if we got lucky and
our initial weight vector
was in the right direction,
so our perceptron
already classified
the answer, then
the weight vector is
never going to change,
because it was already
the right answer.
OK, so let's put it
in another input--
a red input.
You can see that the
correct answer is a zero.
The network gave us
a zero, because it's
on the negative side of the
weight vector of the decision
boundary.
And so, again, delta w is zero.
But let's put in
another input now such
that we get the wrong answer.
So let's put in this
input right here.
So you can see that the answer
here, the correct answer
is one, but the network is
going to give us a zero.
So what do we do to
update that weight vector?
So if the output is not
equal to the correct answer,
then we're wrong.
So now we update w.
And the perceptron learning
rule is very simple.
We introduce a change in
w that looks like this.
It's a little change, so
eps eta is a learning rate.
It's generally going
to be smaller than one.
So we're going to put in
a small change in w that's
in the direction of the
input that was wrong
if the correct answer is a one.
We're going to
make a small change
to w in the opposite
direction of that input
if the correct answer was zero.
Does that make sense?
So we're going to
change w in a way that
depends on what the
input was and what
the correct answer was.
So let's walk through this.
So we put it in an input here.
The correct answer is a one,
and we got the answer wrong.
The network gave us a zero, but
the correct answer is a one.
So we're in this region here.
The answer was incorrect,
so we're going to update w.
The correct answer was a one,
so we're going to change delta--
we're going to change w in
the direction of that input.
So that input is there.
So we're going to add a little
bit to w in this direction.
So if we add that little
bit of vector to the w,
it's going to move the w vector
in this direction, right?
So let's do that.
So there's our new w.
Our new w is the
old plus delta w,
which is in the direction
of this incorrectly
classified input.
So there's our new decision
boundary, all right?
And let's put in another input--
let's say this one right here.
You can see that this input is
also incorrectly classified,
because the correct
answer is a zero.
It's a red dot.
But the network since
it's on the positive side
of the decision boundary.
So the network
classifies it as a one.
OK, good.
So the network classified it
as a one and the correct answer
was a zero, so we were wrong.
So we're going to
update w, and we're
going to update it in the
opposite direction of the input
if the correct answer was
zero, which is the case.
So we're going to update w.
And that's the input xi.
Minus xi is in this direction.
So we're going to update
w in that direction.
So we're going to add those
two vectors to get our new w.
And when we do that,
that's what we get.
There's our new w.
There's our new
decision boundary.
And you can see that that
decision boundary is now
perfectly oriented to separate
the red and the green dots.
So that's Rosenblatt's
perceptron learning rule.
Yes, Rebecca?
AUDIENCE: How do you
change the learning rate?
Because what if it's too big?
You'll sort of get not
helpful [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, that's right.
So if the learning
rate were too big,
you could see this
first correction.
So let's say that we corrected
w but made a correction that
was too far in this direction.
So now the new w
would point up here.
And that would give us,
again, the wrong answer.
What happens, generally,
is that if your learning
rate is too high, then your
weight vector bounces around.
It oscillates around.
So it'll jump too far
this way, and then
it'll get an error
over here, and it'll
jump too far that way.
And then you'll get
an error over there,
and it'll just keep
bouncing back and forth.
So you generally
choose learning rates
that-- the process of
choosing learning rates
can be a little
tricky Basically,
the answer is start small and
increase it until it breaks.
OK, any questions about that?
So you can see it's a
very simple algorithm that
provides a way of changing w
that is guaranteed to converge
toward the best answer
in separating these two
classes of inputs.
All right, so let's go
a little bit further
into single layer
binary networks
and see what they can do.
So these kinds of networks
are very good for actually
implementing logic operations.
So you can see that-- let's say
that we have a perceptron that
looks like this.
Let's give it a threshold
of 0.5 and give it
a weight vector that's 1 and 1.
So you can see that
this perceptron
gives an answer of zero.
The output neuron
has zero firing rate
for an input that's zero.
But any input that's on the
other side of the decision
boundary produces an
output firing rate of one.
What that means is that if
the input a, or u1, is a 1,
0, then the output
neuron will fire.
If the input is 0, 1, the
output neuron will fire.
And if the input is 1, 1,
the output neuron will fire.
So, basically, any input
above some threshold
will make the
output neuron fire.
So this perceptron
implements an OR gate.
If it's input a or input
b, the output neuron
spikes, as long as those inputs
are above some threshold value.
So that's very much
like a logical OR gate.
Now let's see if we can
implement an AND gate.
So it turns out that
implementing an AND gate
is almost exactly
like an OR gate.
We just need-- what would
we change about this network
to implement an AND gate?
AUDIENCE: A larger [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: A larger theta?
MICHALE FEE: Yeah,
a larger theta.
So all we have to do is
move this line up to here.
And now one of
those inputs is not
enough to make the
output neuron fire.
The other input is not enough
to make the output neuron fire.
Only when you have both.
So that implements an AND gate.
We just increase the
threshold a little bit.
Does that make sense?
So we just increase the
threshold here to 1.5.
And now when either input
is on at a value of one,
that's not enough to make
the output neuron fire.
If this input's on,
it's not enough.
If that output is
on, it's not enough.
Only when both inputs are
on do you get enough input
to this output neuron to make
it have a non-zero firing rate,
to get it above threshold.
Now, there's another very common
logic operation that cannot be
solved by a simple perceptron.
That's called an
exclusive OR, where
this neuron, this
network, we want
it to fire only if input a is on
or input b is on, but not both.
Why is it that that
can't be solved
by the kind of perceptron
that we've been describing?
Anybody have some
intuition about that?
AUDIENCE: I mean, it's
obviously [INAUDIBLE] separable.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, that's right.
The keyword there is separable.
If you look at this set of
dots, there's no single line,
there's no single boundary
that separates all the red dots
from off the green dots, OK?
And so that set of inputs
is called non-separable.
And sets of inputs that are not
separable cannot be classified
correctly by a simple perceptron
of the type we've been talking
about.
So how do you
solve that problem?
So this is a set of inputs
that's non-separable.
You can see that you can
solve this problem now
if you have two
separate perceptrons.
So watch this.
We can build one
perceptive one that fires,
that has a positive output
when this input is on.
We can have a separate
perceptron that is active
when that input is on.
And then what would we do?
If we had one
neuron that's active
if that input is
on another input
that's active when
that input is on?
We would or them
together, that's right.
So this is what's known as
a multi-layer perceptron.
We have two inputs, one
that represents activity
in a, another that
represents activity in b.
And we have one neuron
in what's called
the intermediate layer
of our perceptron
that has a weight
vector of 1 minus 1.
What that means is this neuron
will be active if input a is
on but not input b.
This one will be active.
This neuron has a different
weight vector-- minus 1, 1.
This neuron will be active if
input b is on but not input a.
And the output neuron
implements an OR operation
that will be active when this
intermediate neuron is on
or that intermediate
neuron is on, OK?
And so that network altogether
implements this exclusive OR
function.
Does that make sense?
Any questions about that?
So this problem
of separability is
extremely important in
classifying inputs in general.
So if you think about
classifying an image,
like a number or
a letter, you can
see that in high-dimensional
space, images
that are all threes,
let's say, are all
very similar to each other.
But they're actually not
separable in this linear space.
And that's because in the
high dimensional space
they exist on what's
called a manifold
in this high-dimensional
space, OK?
They're like all lined
up on some sheet, OK?
So this is an
example of rotations,
and you can see that all these
different threes kind of sit
along a manifold in this
high-dimensional space that
are separate from all
the other numbers.
So all those numbers
exist on what's
called an invariant
transformation, OK?
Now, how would we
separate those images
of threes from all the
other numbers or letters?
How would we do that?
Well, we could imagine building
a multi-layer perceptron that--
so here, I'm
showing that there's
no single line that separates
the threes on this manifold
from all the other
digits over here.
We can solve that
problem by implementing
a multi-layer perceptron that
while one of those perceptrons
detects these objects,
another perceptron detects
these objects, and then we
can OR those all together.
So that's a kind of
network that can now
detect all of these three,
separate them from non-threes.
Does that make sense?
So we can think of objects that
we recognize, like this three
that we recognize, even
though it has different--
we can recognize it
with different rotations
or transformations
or scale changes.
You can also think of the
problem of separating images
from dogs and cats as
also solving this problem,
that the space of
dogs, of dog images,
somehow lives on a manifold
in the high dimensional space
of inputs that we
can distinguish
from the set of
images of cats that's
some other manifold in this
high-dimensional space.
So it turns out that you need
more than just a single layer
perceptron.
You need more than just
a two-layer perceptron.
In general, the
kinds of networks
that are good for separating
different kinds of images,
like dogs and cats and
cars and houses and faces,
look more like this.
So this is work from
Jim DiCarlo's lab,
where they found evidence that
networks in the brain that do
image classification--
for example,
in the visual pathway--
look a lot like very deep
neural networks, where
you have the retina on the
left side here sending inputs
to another letter
in the thalamus,
sending inputs to v1, to v2,
to v4, and so on, up to IT.
And that we can think
of this as being,
essentially, many stacked
layers of perceptrons
that sort of unravel
these manifolds
in this high-dimensional
space to allow
neurons here at the very
end to separate dogs
from cats from
buildings from faces.
And there are
learning rules that
can be used to train
networks like this
by putting in a bunch of
different images of people
and other different
categories that you
might want to separate.
And then each one
of those images
has a label, just like our
perceptron learning rule.
And we can use the image
and the correct label--
face or dog-- and
train that network
by projecting that information
into these intermediate layers
to train that network
to properly classify
those different stimuli, OK?
This is, basically,
the kind of technology
that's currently
being used to train--
this is being used in AI.
It's being used to
train driverless cars.
All kinds of
technological advances
are based on this kind
of technology here.
Any questions about that?
Aditi?
AUDIENCE: So in
actual neurons, I
assume it's not linear, right?
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
These are all nonlinear neurons.
They're more like these
binary threshold units
than they are like
linear neurons.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: But then do
you there's, like--
because right now, I
imagine that models we make
have to have way more
perceptron units.
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: We use our
simplified [INAUDIBLE]..
But then our brain
is sometimes--
I mean, it's at, like,
a much faster level,
like way faster, right?
So you think it'd be like--
if we examine what functions
neurons might be using, in a
way that would let us reduce
the number of units needed?
Because right now, for
example, [INAUDIBLE]
be a bunch of lines.
But maybe in the brain, there's
some other function it's using,
which is smoother.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
OK, so let me just
make sure I understand.
You're not talking about the
F-I curve of the neurons?
Is that correct?
You're talking about the
way that you figure out
these weights.
Is that what you're
asking about?
AUDIENCE: No.
I'm asking if we use a
more accurate F-I curve,
we'll need less units.
MICHALE FEE: OK, so
that's a good question.
I don't actually know the
answer to the question
of how the specific
choice of F-I curve
affects the performance of this.
The big problem that people
are trying to figure out
in terms of how
these are trained
is the challenge that in
order to train these networks,
you actually need thousands
and thousands, maybe millions,
of examples of different objects
here and the answer here.
So you have to put
in many thousands
of example images and
the answer in order
to train these networks.
And that's not the way
people actually learn.
We don't walk around the
world when we're one-year-old
and our mother saying,
dog, cat, person, house.
You know, it would be... in
order to give a person as many
labeled examples as you
need to give these networks,
you would just be doing nothing,
but your parents would be
pointing things out to you and
telling you one-word answers
of what those are.
Instead, what happens is
we just observe the world
and figure out
kind of categories
based on other sorts of learning
rules that are unsupervised.
We figure out, oh, that's a kind
of thing, and then mom says,
that's a dog.
And then we know that
that category is a dog.
And we sometimes
make mistakes, right?
Like a kid might look
at a bear and say, dog.
And then dad says, no,
no, that's not a dog, son.
So the learning by which
people train their networks
to do classification
of inputs is
quite different from the way
these deep neural networks
work.
And that's a very important
and active area of research.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is the fact that
[INAUDIBLE] use unsupervised
learning, as well,
to train a computer
to recognize an image
of a turtle as a gun,
but humans can't do
that [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Recognize
a turtle if what?
AUDIENCE: Like I saw this
thing where it was like at MIT,
they used an AI.
They manipulated
pixels in images
and convinced the computer
that it was something
that it was not actually.
MICHALE FEE: I see.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So like you would
see a picture of a turtle,
but the computer
would get that picture
and say it was,
like, a machine gun.
MICHALE FEE: Just by
manipulating a few pixels
and kind of screwing
with its mind.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So it's [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
Well, people can be tricked
by different things.
The answer is, yes,
it's related to that.
The problem is after
you do this training,
we actually don't
really understand
what's going on in the
guts of this network.
It's very hard to look at
the inside of this network
after it's trained and
understand what it's doing.
And so we don't
know the answer why
it is that you can fool
one of these networks
by changing a few pixels.
Something goes wrong in here,
and we don't know what it is.
It may very well have to do
with the way it's trained,
rather than building categories
in an unsupervised way, which
could be much more
generalizable.
So good question.
I don't really know the answer.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
can you explain what
you mean [INAUDIBLE] the
neural network needs an answer?
They're not categorized and
then tell the user dogs?
MICHALE FEE: Yeah,
so no, in order
to train one of these networks,
you have to give it a data set,
a labeled data set.
So a set of images that
already has the answer
that was labeled by a person.
AUDIENCE: So you
can't just give it
a set of photos of
puppies and snakes
and it'll categorize
them into two groups?
MICHALE FEE: No, nobody
knows how to do that.
People are working on that,
but it's not known yet.
Yes, Jasmine?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
but I see [INAUDIBLE] I
can't separate them and like
adding an additional feature
to raise it to a higher
dimensional space, where
it's separable?
MICHALE FEE: Sorry, I
didn't quite understand.
Can you say it again?
AUDIENCE: I think I
remember reading somewhere
about how when the scenes
are nonlinearly separable--
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --you can add in
another feature to [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, yeah.
So let me show you
an example of that.
So coming back to
the exclusive OR.
So one thing that
you can do, you
can see that the reason this is
linearly inseparable-- it's not
linearly separable-- is
because all these points are
in a plane.
So there's no line
that separates them.
But one way, one sort
of trick you can do,
is to add noise to this.
So that now, some of
these points move.
You can add another dimension.
So now let's say
that we add noise,
and we just, by chance, happen
to move the green dots this way
and the red dots,
well, that way.
And now there's a plane that
will separate the red dots
from the green dots.
So that's advanced
beyond the scope of what
we're talking about here.
But yes, there are
tricks that you
can play to get around
this exclusive OR
problem, this linear
separability problem, OK?
All right, great question.
All right, let's push on.
So let's talk about
more general two-layer
feed-forward networks.
So this is referred to as a
two-layer network-- an input
layer and an output layer.
And in this case, we had
a single input neuron
and a single output neuron.
We generalized that to having
multiple input neurons and one
output neuron.
We saw that we can write
down the input current
to this output neuron as
w, the vector of weights,
dotted into the vector
of input firing rates
to give us an expression for
the firing rate of the output
neuron.
And now we can
generalize that further
to the case of multiple
output neurons.
So we have multiple input
neurons, multiple output
neurons.
You can see that
we have a vector
of firing rates of
the input neurons
and a vector of firing
rates of the output neurons.
So we used to just have one
of these output neurons,
and now we've got a
whole bunch of them.
And so we have to write
down a vector of fire rates
in the output layer.
And now we can write down
the firing rate of our output
neurons as follows.
So the firing rate
of this neuron
here is going to be a
dot product of the vector
of weights onto it.
So the firing rate
of output neuron one
is the vector of weights onto
that first output neuron dotted
into the vector of
input firing rates.
And the same for the
next output neuron.
The firing rate of
output neuron two
is dot product of the weights
onto that output neuron two
and onto the vector
of input firing rates.
Same for neuron three.
And we can write
that down as follows.
So the eighth output--
the firing rate
of the eighth output
neuron is the weight vector
onto the eighth output neuron
dotted into the input firing
rate vector, OK?
And we can write
that down as follows,
where we've now introduced
a new thing here,
which is a matrix of weights.
So it's called
the weight matrix.
And it essentially
is a matrix of all
of these synaptic weights, from
the input layer onto the output
layer.
And now if we had
a linear neuron,
we can write down the firing
rate of the output neuron.
The firing rate vector
of output neuron
is just this weight matrix times
the vector of input fire rates.
So now, we've
rewritten this problem
of finding the vector
of output firing rates
as a matrix multiplication.
And we're going to spend
some time talking about what
that means and what that does.
So our feed-forward
network implements a matrix
multiplication.
All right, so let's take
a closer look at what
this weight matrix looks like.
So we have a weight matrix w sub
a comma b that looks like this.
So we have four input neurons
and four output neurons.
We have a weight for each input
neuron onto each output neuron.
The columns here correspond
to different input neurons.
The rows correspond to
different output neurons.
Remember, for a
matrix, the elements
are listed as w sub a, b,
where a is the output neuron.
b is the input neuron.
On so it's w postsynaptic,
presynaptic-- post, pre.
Rows, columns.
So the rows are the
different output neurons.
The columns are the
different input neurons.
So it can be a little
tricky to remember.
I just remember that it's rows--
a matrix is labeled
by rows and columns.
And weight matrices are
postsynaptic, presynaptic--
post, pre.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
comment of [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHALE FEE: I think
that's standard.
I'm pretty sure
that's very standard.
If you find any
exceptions let me know.
OK, we can think of
each row of this matrix
as being the vector of weights
onto one output neuron.
That row is a vector of weights
onto that output neuron--
that row, that output neuron;
that row, that output neuron.
Does that makes sense?
All right, so let's flesh out
this matrix multiplication.
The vector of
output firing rates,
we're going to write it
as a column vector, where
the first number is
this firing rate.
That number is that firing rate.
That number represents
that firing rate, OK?
That's equal to
this weight matrix
times the vector of
input firing rates,
again, written as
a column vector.
And in order to calculate the
firing rate of the first output
neuron, we take the dot product
of the first row of the weight
matrix and the column vector
of input firing rates.
And that gives us this
first firing rate, OK?
To get the second
firing rate, we
take the dot product of
the second row of weights
with the vector of firing
rates, and that gives us
this second firing rate.
Any questions about that?
Just a brief reminder of
matrix multiplication.
All right, no questions?
All right, so let's take
a step back and go quickly
through some basic
matrix algebra.
I know most of you have
probably seen this,
but many haven't, so we're
just going to go through it.
All right, so just
as vectors are--
you can think of them as
a collection of numbers
that you write down.
So let's say that you are
making a measurement of two
different things--
let's say temperature
and humidity.
So you can write down a vector
that represents those two
quantities.
So matrices you can think of
as collections of vectors.
So let's say we take
those two measurements
at different times, at
three different times.
So now we have a vector one, a
vector two, and a vector three
that measure those two
quantities at three
different times, all right?
So we can now write all
of those measurements
down as a matrix,
where we collect
each one of those vectors
as a column in our matrix,
like that.
Any questions about that?
And there's a bit of MATLAB
code that calculates this matrix
by writing three
different column vectors
and then concatenating
them into a matrix.
All right, and you can
see that in this matrix,
the columns are just
the original vectors,
and the rows are--
you can think of
those as a time series
of our first measurement,
let's say temperature.
So that's temperature
as a function of time.
This is temperature and
humidity at one time.
Does that make sense?
All right, so, again, we
can write down this matrix.
Remember, this is
the first measurement
at time two, the first
measurement at time three.
We have two rows
and three columns.
We can also write
down what's known
as the transpose of a matrix
that just flips the rows
and columns.
So we can write
transpose, which is
indicated by this
capital super scripted t.
And here, we're just flipping
the rows and columns.
So the first row of this
matrix becomes the first column
of the transposed matrix.
So we have three
rows and two columns.
A symmetric matrix--
I'm just defining
some terms now.
A symmetric matrix
is a matrix where
the off-diagonal elements--
so let me just define,
that's the diagonal,
the matrix diagonal.
And a symmetric matrix
has the property
that the off-diagonal
elements are zero.
And a symmetric matrix
has the property
that the transpose of that
matrix is equal to the matrix,
OK?
That is only
possible, of course,
if the matrix has the same
number of rows and columns,
if it's what's called
a square matrix.
Let me just remind
you, in general
about matrix multiplication.
We can write down the
product of two matrices.
And we do that multiplication
by taking the dot product
of each row in the first
matrix with each column
in the second matrix.
So here's the product of
matrix A and matrix B.
So there's the product.
If this matrix, if
matrix A, is an m by k--
m rows by k columns--
and matrix B has k
rows by n columns,
then the product of
those two matrices
will have m by n
rows and columns.
And you can see that in order
for matrix multiplication
to work, the number of
columns of the first matrix
equal the number of rows
in the second matrix.
You can see that this k has to
be the same for both matrices.
Does that make sense?
So, again, in order to compute
this element right here,
we take the dot product
of the first row of A
and the first column of B.
That's just 1 times 4, is 4.
Plus negative 2
times 7 is minus 14.
Plus 0 times minus 1 is 0.
Add those up and
you get minus 10.
So you get this number.
You multiply this
row dot product
this row with this
column and so on.
Notice, A times B is
not equal to B times A.
In fact, in cases of rectangular
matrices, matrices that aren't
square, you can't
even do this, often do
this, multiplication
in a different order.
Mathematically, it
doesn't make sense.
So let's say that we
have a matrix of vectors,
and we want to take
the dot product
of each one of those vectors
x with some other vector v. So
let's just write that down.
The way to do that is
to say the answer here,
the dot product of each
one of those column vectors
in our matrix with
this other vector
v we do by taking
the transpose of v,
which takes a column vector
and turns it into a row vector.
And we can now multiply
that by our data matrix x
by taking the dot product
of v with that column of x.
And that gives us a matrix.
So this matrix here, that
vector is a one by two matrix.
This is a two by three matrix.
The product of those is
a one by three matrix.
Any questions about that?
OK.
We can do this a different way.
Notice that the result
of this multiplication
here is a row vector, y.
We can do this a different way.
We can take dot product.
We can also compute this
as y equals x transpose v.
So here, we've taken the
transpose of the data
matrix times this
column vector v.
And again, we take the
dot product of this,
this with this,
and that with that.
And now we get a
column vector that
has the same entries
that we had over here.
All right, so I'm just
showing you different ways
that you can manipulate
a vector in a matrix
to compute the dot product
of elements of vectors
within a data matrix
and other vectors
that you're interested in.
All right, identity matrix.
So when you're multiplying
numbers together,
the number one has
the special property
that you can multiply
any real number by one
and get the same number back.
You have the same kind
of element in matrices.
So is there a matrix that when
multiplied by A gives you A?
And the answer is yes.
It's called the identity matrix.
So it's given by the
symbol I, usually.
A times I equals A. What
does that matrix look like?
Again, the identity
matrix looks like this.
It's a square matrix that
has ones along the diagonal
and zero everywhere else.
So you can see here that if
you take an arbitrary vector x,
multiplied by the
identity matrix,
you can see that this product
is x1, x2 dotted into 1,
0, which gives you x1.
x1, x2 dotted into
0, 1, gives you x2.
And so the answer looks
like that, which is just x.
So the identity matrix
times an arbitrary vector x
gives you x back.
Another very useful
application of linear algebra,
linear algebra tools, is to
solve systems of equations.
So let me show you
what that looks like.
So let's say we want to solve
a simple equation, ax equals c.
So, in this case, how
do you solve for x?
Well, you're just going to
divide both sides by a, right?
So if you divide
both sides by a,
you get that x equals
1 over a times c.
So it turns out that there
is a matrix equivalent
of that, that allows you to
solve systems of equations.
So if you have a
pair of equations--
x minus 2y equals 3 and
3x plus y equals 5--
you can write this down
as a matrix equation,
where you have a
matrix 1, minus 2,
3, 1, which correspond to
the coefficients of x and y
in these equations.
Times a vector xy is equal
to 3, 5, another vector 3, 5.
So you can write this
down as ax equals c--
that's kind of nice--
where this matrix A is
given by these coefficients
and this vector c is
given by these terms
on this side of the equation, on
the right side of the equation.
Now, how do we solve this?
Well, can we just divide both
sides of that matrix equation,
that vector equation, by a?
So division is not really
defined for matrices,
but we can use another trick.
We can multiply both
sides of this equation
by something that
makes the a go away.
And so that magical thing
is called the inverse of A.
So we take the
inverse of matrix A,
denoted by A with this
superscript minus 1.
And that's the standard notation
for identifying the inverse.
It has the property
that A inverse times
A equals the identity matrix.
So you can sort of
think about this
as A equals the identity matrix
over A. Anyway, don't really
think of it like that.
So to solve this system
of equations ax equals c,
we multiply both sides
by that A inverse matrix.
And so that looks like this--
A inverse A times x
equals A inverse c.
A inverse A is just what?
The identity matrix times
x equals A inverse c.
And we just saw before that
identity matrix times x
is just x.
All right, so
there's the solution
to this system of equations.
All right, any
questions about that?
So how do you find the
inverse of a matrix?
What is this A inverse?
How do you get it in real life?
So in real life, what
you usually do is
you would just use the matrix
inverse function in Matlab.
Because for any matrices
other than a two-by-two,
it's really annoying to
get a matrix inverse.
But for a two-by-two matrix,
it's actually pretty easy.
You can almost just get the
answer by looking at the matrix
and writing down the inverse.
It looks like this.
The inverse of a two-by-two
square matrix is just given
by a slight reordering
of the coefficients,
of the entries of that matrix,
divided by what's called
the determinant of A. So
what you do is you flip--
in a two-by-two matrix,
you flip the A and the D,
and then you multiply the
diagonal elements by minus 1.
Now, what is this determinant?
The determinant is given by
a times d minus b times c.
And you can prove
that that actually
is the inverse, because if we
take this and multiply it by A,
what you find when you multiply
that out is that that's just
equal to the identity matrix.
So a matrix has an
inverse if and only
if the determinant
is not equal to zero.
If the determinant
is equal to zero,
you can see that
this thing blows up,
and there's no inverse.
We're going to spend
a little bit of time
later talking about what
that means when a matrix has
an inverse and what the
determinant actually
corresponds to in a matrix
multiplication context.
If the determinant
is equal to zero,
we say that that
matrix is singular.
And in that case, you can't
actually find an inverse,
and you can't solve this
equation right here,
this system of equations.
All right, so let's actually
go through this example.
So here's our
equation, ax equals c.
We're going to use the
same matrix we had before
and the same c.
The determinant is
just the product
of those minus the product of
those, so 1 minus negative 6.
So the determinant is 7.
So there is an inverse
of this matrix.
And we can just write
that down as follows.
Again, we've flipped those
two and multiplied those
by minus 1.
So we can solve for x just by
taking that inverse times c,
A inverse times c.
And if you multiply
that out, you
see that there's the inverse.
It's just a vector.
That's it.
That's how you solve a system
of equations, all right?
Any questions about that?
So this process of solving
systems of equations
and using matrices
and their inverses
to solve systems of equations
is a very important concept
that we're going to use
over and over again.
All right, let's
turn to the topic
of matrix transformations.
All right, so you can see
from this problem of solving
this system of equations that
that matrix A transformed
a vector x into a vector c, OK?
So we have this vector x, which
was 3/7 minus 4/7 a vector.
When we multiplied that by
A, we got another vector, c.
And the vector A inverse
transforms this vector
c back into vector x, right?
So we can take that vector
c, multiply it by A inverse,
and get back to x.
Does that make sense?
So, in general, a
matrix A maps a set
of vectors in this whole space.
So if you have a
two-by-two vector,
it maps a set of vectors
in R2 onto a different set
of vectors in R2.
So you can take
any vector here--
a vector from the
origin into here--
multiply that vector
by A, and it gives you
a different vector.
And if you multiply that
other vector by A inverse,
you go back to the
original vector.
So this vector A
implements some kind
of transformation on this
space of real numbers
into a different space
of real numbers, OK?
And you can only do this
inverse if the determinant of A
is not equal to zero.
So I just want to show you
what different kinds of matrix
transformations look like.
So let's start with the
simplest matrix transformation--
the identity matrix.
So if we take a
vector x, multiply it
by the identity matrix,
you get another vector y,
which is equal to x.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to kind of riff off
of a theme here, and
we're going to take
slight perturbations
of the identity matrix
and see what that new matrix
does to a set of input vectors,
OK?
So let me show you how
we're going to do that.
We're going to take it the
identity matrix 1, 0, 0, 1.
And we're going to add
a little perturbation
to the diagonal elements.
And we're going to see what that
does to a set of input vectors.
So let me show you
what we're doing here.
We have each one
of these red dots.
So what I did was I generated
a bunch of random numbers
in a 2D space.
So this is a 2D space.
And I just randomly
selected a bunch
of numbers, a bunch of
points on that plane.
And each one of those
is an input vector x.
And then I multiplied
that vector
times this slightly
perturbed identity matrix.
And then I get a bunch
of output vectors y.
Input vectors x
are the red dots.
The output vectors y are the
other end of this blue line.
Does that make sense?
So for every vector x,
multiplying it by this matrix
gives me another vector
that's over here.
Does that make sense?
So you can see that
what this matrix does
is it takes this space,
this cloud of points,
and stretches them
equally in all directions.
So it takes any vector
and just makes it longer,
stretches it out.
No matter which
direction it's pointing,
it just makes that
vector slightly longer.
And here's that
little bit of code
that I used to
generate those vectors.
OK, so let's take
another example.
Let's say that we take
the identity matrix
and we just add a little
perturbation to one element
of the identity matrix, OK?
So what does that do?
It stretches the vectors
out in the x direction,
but it doesn't do anything
to the y direction.
So the vector with a
component in the x direction,
the x component gets increased
by an by a factor 1 plus delta.
The components of each of these
vectors in the y direction
don't change, all right?
So we're going to take
this cloud of points,
and we're going to stretch
it in the x direction.
What about this matrix here?
What's that going to do?
AUDIENCE: Stretch it
in the y direction.
MICHALE FEE: Good.
It's going to stretch it
out in the y direction.
Good.
So that's kind of cute.
And you can see that this
earlier matrix that we looked
at right here stretches
in the x direction
and stretches in
the y direction.
And that's why that
cloud of vectors
just stretched out
equally in all directions.
Out this.
What is that going to do?
AUDIENCE: It would stretch in
the x direction and compress
in the y direction
MICHALE FEE: Right.
This perturbation here
is making this component,
the x component larger.
This perturbation here--
and delta here is small.
It's less than one.
Here, it's making the
y component smaller.
And so what that looks like
is the y component of each one
of these vectors gets smaller.
The x component gets larger.
And so we're squeezing
in one direction
and stretching in
the other direction.
Imagine we took
a block of sponge
and we grabbed it
and stretched it out,
and it gets skinny
in this direction
and stretches out
in that direction.
All right, that's kind of cool.
What is this going to do?
Here, I'm not making a
small perturbation of this,
but I'm flipping the
sign of one of those.
What happens there?
What is that going to do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
What do we call that?
There's a term for it.
What do you-- yeah, it's
called a mirror reflection.
So every point that's on
this side of the origin
gets reflected over to
this side of the origin.
And every point
that's over here--
sorry, of this axis.
Every point that's on
this side of the y-axis
gets reflected
over to this side.
So that's called a
mirror reflection.
What is this?
What is that going to do?
Abiba?
AUDIENCE: Reflect
it [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Right.
It's going to reflect it
through the origin, like this.
So every point that's over
here, on one side of the origin,
is going to reflect
through to the other side.
That's pretty neat.
Inversion of the origin.
OK?
So we have symmetric
perturbations
in the x and y components
of the identity matrix.
We have a stretch transformation
that stretches along one axis,
but not the other.
Stretch around the other axis,
the y-axis, but not the x-axis.
Stretch along x and
compression along y.
Mirror reflection
through the y-axis.
Inversion through the origin.
These are examples of
diagonal matrices, OK?
So the only thing
we've done so far--
we've gotten all these
really cool transformations,
but the only thing
we've done so far
are change these two
diagonal elements.
So there's a lot
more crazy stuff
to happen if we start messing
with the other components.
Oh, and I should mention
that we can invert
any one of these transformations
that we just did by finding
the inverse of this matrix.
The inverse of a diagonal matrix
is very simple to calculate.
It's just one over
those diagonal elements.
All right, how about this?
What is that going to do?
Anybody?
When you take a vector
and you multiply it
by that, what's going to happen?
This part is going to give
you the original vector back.
This part is going to take a
little bit of the y component
and add it to the x component.
So what does that do?
That produces what's
known as a shear.
So points up here,
we're going to take
a little bit of the y component
and add it to the x component.
So if something has
a big y component,
it's going to be shifted in x.
If something has a
negative y component,
it's going to shift
this way in x.
If something has a
positive y component,
it's going to shift
this way an x.
And it's going to produce
what's called a shear.
So we're pushing
these points this way,
pushing those points this way.
Shear is very important in
things like the flow of liquid.
So when you have liquid
flowing over a surface,
you have forces, frictional
forces to the liquid down here
that prevent it from moving.
Liquid up here
moves more quickly,
and it produces a shear in the
pattern of velocity profiles.
OK, that's pretty cool.
What about this?
It's going to just
produce a shear
along the other direction.
That's right.
So now components that have a--
vectors that have a
large x component acquire
a negative projection in y.
OK, what does this look like?
It's pretty cool.
We're going to get some
shear in this direction,
get some shear in
this direction.
What's it going to do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
Good guess.
That's exactly right,
produces a rotation.
Not exactly a rotation,
but very close.
So that's how you actually
produce a rotation.
So notice, for small angles
theta, these are close to one,
so it's close to
an identity matrix.
These are close to zero,
but this is negative
and this is positive,
or the other way around.
So if we have diagonals close
to one and the off-diagonals one
positive and one negative,
then that produces a rotation.
That, formally, is
a rotation matrix.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: On the
previous slide, is there
a reason you chose to represent
the delta on the x-axis as
negative?
MICHALE FEE: No.
It goes either way.
So if you have a rotation
angle that's positive,
then this is negative
and this is positive.
If your rotation angle
is the other sign,
then this is positive
and this is negative.
So, for example, if we want to
produce a 45-degree rotation,
then we have 1, 1, minus 1, 1.
And of course, all those
things have a square root
of 2, 1 over square
root of 2, in them.
And so that looks like this.
So if you have, let's say,
theta equals 10 degrees,
we can produce a 10-degree
rotation of all the vectors.
If theta is 25
degrees, you can see
that the rotation is further.
Theta 45, that's
this case right here.
You can see that you get a
45-degree rotation of all
of those vectors
around the origin.
And if theta is 90 degrees,
you can see that, OK?
Pretty cool, right?
OK, what is the inverse
of this rotation matrix?
So if we have a
rotation-- oh, and I just
want to point out
one more thing.
In this formulation of
the rotation matrix,
positive angles correspond
to rotating counterclockwise.
Negative angles
correspond to rotation
in the clockwise direction, OK?
So there's a big hint.
What is the inverse of
our rotation matrix?
If we have a rotation
of 10 degrees this way,
what is the inverse of that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Right.
MICHALE FEE: That's right.
Remember, matrix multiplication
implements a transformation.
The inverse of
that transformation
just takes you back
where you were.
So if you have a rotation
matrix that you implemented
a 20-degree rotation
in the plus direction,
then the inverse of that
is a 20-degree rotation
in the minus direction.
So the inverse of
this matrix you
can get just by putting in
a minus sign into the theta.
And you can see that
cosine of minus theta
is just cosine of theta.
But sine of minus theta
is negative sine of theta.
So the inverse of this
matrix is just this.
You change the sign
of those diagonals,
which just makes the shear go in
the opposite direction, right?
OK, so a rotation
by angle plus theta
followed by a rotation
of angle minus theta
puts everything
back where it was.
So rotation matrix phi of
minus theta times phi of theta
is equal to the identity matrix.
So those two are
inverses of each other.
And the inverse of a--
notice that the inverse
of this rotation matrix
is also just the transpose
of the rotation matrix.
All right, so what
you can see is
that these different
cool transformations
that these matrix
multiplications can do
are just examples of what our
feed-forward network can do.
Because the feed-m
forward network
just implements
matrix multiplication.
So this feed-forward
network takes
a set of vectors, a
set of input vectors,
and transforms them into a set
of output vectors, all right?
And you can understand what
that transformation does just
by understanding the different
kinds of transformations
you can get from
matrix multiplication.
All right, we'll
continue next time.